nous sommes ici
devant l'hôpital les esclaves
et nous allons vous présenter là
famille karl c'était en 1998
notre association l'association coville
elle crée depuis 1993 et fédérer cers en
de mémoire en quête de son enquête de
son histoire et pas dans le 150e
anniversaire de l'abolition esclavage
nous avons voulu faire des recherches
généalogiques
nous avons constaté que en 1848 les
patronymes attribué à aux esclaves de
cette ancienne plantation de ses
patronymes là on l'on retrouve encore à
villèle et nous en avons contacté
messieurs arsène carlo et nous a donné
l'autorisation
et nous avons entrepris des recherches
généalogiques aux archives
départementales
après les avoir faits aux mairies bien
sûr on a pu remonter très très très très
loin par la famille carlo fait partie
des premiers premiers esclaves des 17
familles et la surprise est que nous
sommes tombés sur véronique tard l'eau
qui était heureux dicarlo
c'était une infirmière à l'hôpital les
esclaves nous trouvons devant cet
hôpital par hasard c'est pour mieux
connaître où elle travaillait véronique
carlo fait partie des ancêtres de arsène
parle où elle est décédée même est ici
dans
l'enchère chorale de 20 m du bassin à
villèle en 1852 et par rapport à nos
connaissances au musée de villèle nous
avons fait appel à une artiste madame
anne-marie valencien elle va faire un
très très beau un très bon travail et
d'ailleurs mais chez arsene carlo s'est
rendu plusieurs fois à son atelier sa
maison même à l'église près de l'église
de saint juniauds et il va dessiner
arsène car l'ol va faire une très très
belle présentation vous parlez bien au
niveau de la généalogie en bas là à
l'époque du rhône et carlo des saisons
quand même c'est très sombre et l'idée
est d'aider les artistes de nous mêmes
et t2 faire en sorte que
il y a c'est tout ce côté ses côtés
difficile à l'époque de l'esclavagé et à
l'abolition est plus à monter puis ça
monte on recourt on remarque qui a plus
de lumière et ses lumières quoique ont
montré à l'époque n'est ce pas là
c'était difficile et puis ça monte
oui il ya un an on va dire plus de
sourires sur les visages des
et des gens véronique carlo on veut la
revoir sur la généalogie qui se trouvent
dans l'hôpital des esclaves